[Musique]
il a presque quotidienne régionale il
est télévision locale vous présente le
club des territoires
et on va donc analyser ces résultats
avec la presse régionale et d'abord une
question il y a beaucoup de choses à
retenir de ces résultats d'hier vous
Nathalie qu'est-ce que vous en retenez
de ce qui s'est passé hier soir trois
choses très simples la première une
victoire nette d'Emmanuel Macron et donc
incontestable
la deuxième c'est une victoire qui
arrive dans une France fracturée
et à mon avis c'est un grand grand défi
pour le président a élu et la troisième
c'est la poussée de la candidate issue
de l'extrême droite juste un chiffre
pour rappel en 2017 il y avait deux
départements où elle était arrivée en
tête au second tour l'aine et le
Pas-de-Calais cette fois-ci j'ai pas le
chiffre exact mais c'est plus d'une
vingtaine je crois que c'est tout ça il
a la carte
et et voilà et c'est ce qui illustre mon
deuxième point c'est à dire on est dans
une France fracturée une France des
métropoles versus une France plus rurale
et c'est un gros gros gros défi pour
Emmanuel Macron voilà on va revenir
effectivement sur cette carte des
territoires qui est riche en
enseignement vous avez raison Nathalie
Stéphane mais pas mieux je trouve que
les analyses natalité excellente on peut
s'arrêter presque merci Nathalie
les défis enfin parmi les choses
importantes qui se sont passées hier en
fait la vraie question maintenant c'est
comment gouverner dans les 5 ans qui
viennent dans un pays qui effectivement
est très divisé très fracturé
pour ça il faudrait il faudrait que
Macron puisse avoir une bonne assise et
ce qui lui aurait donné une bonne assise
c'est une victoire nette c'est le cas
avec une participation très forte ça
c'est pas le cas du tout et on voit même
très nettement que dans certaines zones
le front tout senti Macron a marché à
plein je trouve que pour ça les
résultats les outre-mer sont
spectaculaires plus de 60% de votes
Jean-Luc mél compromis tour plus de 60%
de vote Marine Le Pen au second tour ça
a dit bien où on en est et maintenant
toute la difficulté pour ce nouveau
président réélu c'est comment on fait
pour recoudre comme disait Marine Le Pen
comment on fait pour rassembler les
Français et gouverner sans s'en sortir
un troisième tour au législatives dans
la rue des contestations incessantes et
qu'il arrive qu'il a qu'il puisse aller
au bout de ce mandat et mener à bien les
réformes qu'il a promis de faire avant
avant échéance et ça c'est pas gagné
je retiens une image en fait celle de du
Champ de Mars déserté très tôt hier soir
qui montre que la bamboche elle a déjà
terminé elle est déjà terminée et
Emmanuel Macron l'a montré au travers de
son de son discours qui était assez
assez
plat faut bien faut bien admettre il a
coché toutes les cages des cases des
spin doctors qui lui ont dit attention
il faut bien placer
bienveillance
recoudre la France enfin bref tout tous
les mots qui fallait qu'il fallait dire
méthode renouvelée et pourtant des mots
qui avaient déjà été utilisés il y a il
y a 5 ans pour dire qu'il fallait
prendre en compte les colères de de
cette France
l'avantage c'est que cette fois-ci il
n'a même pas dit qu'il allait résoudre
le vote de l'extrême droite je crois
qu'il en a fait son son deuil malgré
tout il reste la grande difficulté c'est
à dire que c'est un président qui en
effet a été élu très nettement mais mal
réélu alors c'est pas le plus mal réélu
de la Cinquième République parce que
grâce à Pompidou il reste le deuxième
enfin c'est pas quand même très glorieux
et surtout ça montre encore une fois que
c'est la victoire d'une France
le politologue Jérôme Fourquet la montré
ces derniers jours c'est la France la
France qui va bien la France de
l'ascension sociale qui qui l'emporte
face à la France des déclassés et cette
transe des déclassée
risque de vouloir un troisième tour soit
dans la rue soit législatives et on va
parler tout ça mais ce que vous avez
parlé du discours d'Emmanuel Macron
avant d'entendre Olivier puisque
ce qu'on va entendre d'Emmanuel Macron
Olivier Biscaye il s'est adressé hier au
Champ de Mars très rapidement aux
électeurs qui ont voté pour Marine Le
Pen et qui ont voté pour lui sans
conviction mais pour faire barrage à
Marine Le Pen il leur promet d'être le
président de tous il en premier une
réponse on écoute
ce jour pour moi non pour soutenir les
idées que je porte mais pour faire
barrage à celle de l'extrême droite
je veux ici
[Musique]
les remercier et leur dire que j'ai
conscience que ce vote m'oblige pour les
années à venir
dès à présent
je ne suis plus le candidat d'un camp
mais le président de toutes et tous et
je sais que pour nombre de nos
compatriotes
qui ont choisi aujourd'hui l'extrême
droite
la colère et les désaccords qui les ont
conduits à voter pour ce projet
doivent aussi trouver une réponse ce
sera ma responsabilité et celle de ceux
qui m'entourent
par la une le Midi Libre ce matin
entendait et agissez c'est le message
que vous avez fait passer
oui en effet
ça ne peut pas être simplement une
phrase d'estrade et je rejoins en cela
vos invités sur sur le plateau Emmanuel
Macron à aligné tout un tas de
d'éléments de langage pour essayer de
rassurer les Français rassurer les
citoyens sur ce qu'ils viennent se
passer il faut maintenant qu'il soit
dans le dans le concret recoudre la
France qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
comment on intègre mieux les Français
comment on les réunit dans un projet
collectif commun comment comment leur
décision leur implication leurs colères
sont prises en compte par le
gouvernement ça ça devrait être concret
il faut rapidement qu'il puisse le faire
il sera un petit Président si il en
reste au discours du Champ de Mars hier
soir il sera un grand président s'il
arrive à convaincre les Français les
électeurs ceux qui ont voté pour Marine
Le Pen ceux qui se sont abstenus ceux
qui ont voté blanc bref tous ceux qui
ont dit non Emmanuel Macron qu'il est
capable et bien de de recréer une
cohésion et pas simplement me
semble-t-il dans
l'alignement de mesure de programmes là
clairement il y a une cohésion à
retrouver de la fierté et penser que
c'est possible en France de de
s'exprimer d'être d'être dans le projet
collectif et ça je crois que c'est très
très difficile donc ça se jouera
évidemment par le Président de la
République ça va se jouer aussi avec les
parlementaires de la République en
marche qui qui seront élus les douze et
19 juin 19 juin au second tour et qui
devront être les meilleurs relais des
des Français donc ça veut dire aussi une
application des cours intermédiaires et
peut-être un renouvellement des profils
dans certaines instances donc là ça
c'est très concret et je trouve que les
prochains jours doivent être conduits
autour de cette thématique là pour en
effet entendre et agir Olivier puisque
vous parlez de cohésion on le voit que
malgré le résultat net hier soir
d'Emmanuel Macron c'est une France
fracturée ce matin Alex vous avez
analysé vous le vote territoire par
territoire mais oui on va d'abord
regarder et bien la carte des résultats
département
département et on va voir qu'Emmanuel
Macron l'emporte dans une majorité de
départements français ou et bien en
majorité on a voté pour Emmanuel Macron
sauf certains départements qui sont en
gris sur notre carte plusieurs
départements du Nord de l'Est de la
France de départements dans le Sud-Ouest
le Lot-et-Garonne le Tarn-et-Garonne les
territoires méditerranéens et puis
évidemment l'outre-mer on va y revenir
au Marine Le Pen a fait de très bons
scores donc c'est une performance qui
est bien meilleure pour Marine Le Pen
qu'en 2017 effectivement vous le disiez
Nathalie Marine Le Pen avait à l'époque
remporté seulement deux départements on
va regarder maintenant et bien la carte
commune par commune ça donne ça donne
une autre idée finalement de la France
qui sort de cette élection
présidentielle c'est plus diffus avec
deux nuages de couleurs qui se
distinguent un nuage jaune on voit que
notamment l'ouest de la France a voté
majoritairement pour Emmanuel Macron
contrairement aux nord-est littoral
méditerranéen et à la vallée de la
Garonne qui se dessine et qui s'est
porté davantage sur le vote Marine Le
Pen mais ça ne dit pas tout de cette
analyse territoriale de ce second tour
de la présidentielle il faut regarder
aussi la taille des différentes
agglomérations et voir le vote en
fonction de la taille des communes
Marine Le Pen arrive en tête dans les
villages les communes rurales de moins
de 2000 habitants avec quand même un
score serré un 51 49 dans les petites
villes entre 2000 et dans les villes
entre 2000 et 100 000 habitants là c'est
Emmanuel Macron qui est en tête avec à
chaque fois et bien un score en moyenne
de
53-47 et puis Emmanuel Macron se
distingue nettement en revanche dans les
grandes villes et les métropoles
63% pour 37% pour Marine Le Pen et puis
dans la capitale et sa banlieue 71% pour
Emmanuel Macron quelques villes quelques
résultats ville par ville Alex ah oui
justement pour bien illustrer c'est très
bon score d'Emmanuel Macron dans les
grandes et bien on peut dire qu'à Paris
intra-muros Emmanuel Macron a fait 87% à
Rennes 84 % un an 80%
79% à Grenoble 76% à Lille ça c'est pour
les scores d'Emmanuel Macron dans les
métropoles cartes ton plan cette fois-ci
pour Marine Le Pen dans les territoires
ultramarins en outre-mer et notamment en
Guadeloupe Marine Le Pen a fait 70% et
puis environ 60% en Martinique en Guyane
et à la Réunion Marine Le Pen qui est
également on disait et bien très
performante dans les communes rurales et
il y avait une commune rurale qui était
scrutée de très près par le gouvernement
il s'agit de Prades dans les
Pyrénées-Orientales une commune qui a
été dirigée par le Premier ministre
actuel Jean Castex et bien Marine Le Pen
l'a emporté à Prades avec 51% des voix
merci beaucoup Alex pour ces résultats
on va évidemment y revenir Nathalie on
le voit plus la commune est petite pure
Marine Le Pen fait des bons scores et
inversement plus on arrive vers des
métropoles et plus là c'est Emmanuel
Macron qui l'emporte largement il y a
une vraie fracture territoriale entre la
France rurale et la France urbaine
aujourd'hui
il y a non seulement il y a cette
fracture là on peut aussi extrapoler il
y a aussi une fracture au niveau de
socio-économique enfin des classes
sociales puisque on voit que Emmanuel
Macron a été élu à plus de 70% par les
aînés par ceux qui ont plus de 65 ans et
par 71% des cadres en revanche il est un
petit peu plus de 30% chez les ouvriers
et on voit que Marine Le Pen est aussi
en tête chez les salariés du privé donc
c'est vraiment une une France en noir et
blanc enfin j'allais dire gris clair et
gris foncé mais en tous les cas très
tranchés comment on fait là maintenant
au lendemain de la présidentielle pour
réconcilier tout le monde c'est
extrêmement compliqué on le voit dès
hier soir moi c'est la première fois que
je vois ça dès hier soir à part le
président de la République tout le monde
se projette dans le troisième tour
c'est-à-dire dans les élections
législatives Marine Le Pen des 20h10 ou
20h20 je sais plus à quelle heure elle a
parlé et Éric Zemmour les autres parties
d'opposition on voit qu'on est dans un
moment de recomposition intense donc ça
va être une semaine compliquée on va
évidemment revenir sur les législatives
mais pour rester sur cette carte de
france du vote puisqu'on a la chance
d'avoir des représentants des
différentes régions je vais vous donner
la parole Stéphane Vernet vous
représenter l'ouest de la France aussi
un peu quand même avec Ouest-France et
du coup
là on voit ses cartons plein pour
Emmanuel Macron dans l'Ouest après on
parlera du Nord avec vous Julien et puis
du Sud avec Olivier et Guilhem oui alors
il y a une c'est aussi parce que dans
l'Ouest il y a une très forte tradition
républicaine des démocrates chrétienne
centriste humaniste qui fait que le le
vote rassemblement national ou Front
National a toujours été assez faible
ceci dit d'année en année il ne cesse de
progresser et on a insisté sur la la
fracture territoriale
entre ville campagne il y a une
spécificité des territoires de l'Ouest
notamment en Bretagne c'est que vous
avez un mariage territorial très
important vous avez beaucoup de petits
pôles de centralité et c'est pas on a la
même problématique qu'ailleurs
c'est-à-dire avec des métropoles qui
grossissent beaucoup et des périphéries
qui sont plus ou moins en difficulté
mais il y a quand même ce maillage
territorial qui fait qu'on le le cette
difficulté là est moins accusée que dans
d'autres régions et je pense que ça en
France qui se sont oubliés
elle existe aussi mais je pense que
cette cette fracture là à mon avis est
moins importante que dans d'autres
régions parce qu'on a encore ce maillage
territorial très important et une
organisation du territoire qui fait
qu'il y a des solidarités des proximités
qui jouent peut-être mieux notamment en
Bretagne qu'ailleurs ça peut être une
des explications sur le fait que ce vote
soit moins fort mais derrière tout cela
moi ce que je vois beaucoup c'est
effectivement cette dialectique entre
les métropoles et les périphéries
c'est des choses qui ont été étudiées
développées au cours des dernières
années et je pense que quand on voit les
résultats c'est une des clés de lecture
à nouveau pour pour les pour les scores
qu'on observe aujourd'hui et en revanche
Julien vous dans les Hauts-de-France et
notamment dans le Nord dans le
Pas-de-Calais terre électoral de Marine
Le Pen elle réalise de bons scores
de mon score dans l'ensemble des des
Hauts de France elle était en tête de
mémoire il y a 5 ans dans deux
départements elle est dans tout sauf le
Nord et dans le Pas-de-Calais elle fait
des des scores enfin c'est du plébiscite
ça a plus de 70% dans certaines communes
et Emmanuel Macron finalement ne réussit
à surnager largement quand même dans les
territoires qui vont bien
notamment dans les grandes villes mais
aussi dans certaines zones rurales qui
sont plutôt aisés et ça aussi ça marque
évidemment la dichotomie entre la encore
une fois la France qui va bien et puis
la France qui va mal mais au-delà de ça
moi j'avais en tête justement je recite
Jérôme Fourquet j'aime beaucoup mais il
avait il nous avait présenté il y a
quelques jours une deux cartes qui
étaient qui étaient absolument
saisissante qui montrait la France en
1963 et la France en 2015 avec la France
qui qui se sentait déclassé et celle qui
était qui était pessimiste sur son
avenir et ce qui était optimiste sur son
avenir en 1963 c'était la Bretagne qui
semblait la plus pessimiste alors que le
nord-est se sentait confiant dans
l'avenir en 2015 c'est totalement
l'inverse on s'aperçoit que la que la
Bretagne tout cet axe où on voit les
meilleurs scores de d'Emmanuel Macron
finalement qui a bénéficié à la fois de
du tourisme de l'implantation de
nouvelles de nouvelles entreprises de
nouveaux actifs plus aisés c'est
développé et plus confiante et
finalement se retrouve dans cette France
d'Emmanuel Macron alors que le
Nord-Pas-de-Calais a vécu très
difficilement des industriels veillent
très difficilement se déclassement et à
le sentiment qu'elle vit beaucoup moins
bien que c'est que ses parents ce qui
n'est pas forcément le cas mais en tout
cas c'est en tout cas c'est le vécu et
cette France cela des des déclassés qui
voient la mondialisation comme une
menace sur ses emplois elle n'est pas
prêt à donner son blanc sein Emmanuel
Macron aujourd'hui les Bretons les
Bretonnes sont ceux qui se disent le
plus attachés à leur alors région sur
l'ensemble du du pays on est près de 80
% de plus quasiment 80 % de gens qui se
disent particulièrement attachés à la
région on sait des scores quasi
sosiettiques et on est sur place sur
toutes les autres régions l'illustration
de ce que vous disiez sur le Grand Est
où toute la zone qui en 1963 tirer la
France vers le haut il y avait les hauts
fourneaux la sidérurgie etc qui
aujourd'hui est totalement désinstruée
des industrialisés donc la Meuse la
Haute-Marne etc tout ça c'est c'est
totalement favorable à Marine Le Pen et
on voit que dans l'Est de la France les
régions qui vont le mieux sont les
régions par exemple où il y a les
stations de ski ou c'est plus up c'est à
dire les savoirs voilà tout ce qui est
dans cette région Rhône-Alpes pour pour
Emmanuel Macron on va aller dans le sud
justement retrouver Olivier Guilhem que
je salue bonjour Guilhem ricagé
directeur des rédactions de la Provence
je vous donne la parole en quelques
instants mais Olivier on le voit cette
fois-ci contrairement à 2017 il y a des
départements en région Occitanie ou
Marine Le Pen est arrivé en tête
oui Oriane c'est le cas par exemple dans
dans le gars c'est le cas dans les dans
l'Aude
c'est également le cas dans les dans les
Pyrénées-Orientales 3 départements qui
qui ont vu Marine Le Pen arrivé
largement en tête avec des villes dans
dans d'autres départements comme
l'Hérault qui
qui permettent à Marine Le Pen d'être en
tête je pense à Béziers je pense à Agde
je pense à Bagnols dans le Gard qui sont
des villes qui sont des villes moyennes
et on passe la parole à Guilhem Guilhem
également dans le sud-est percé de
Marine Le Pen
oui très clairement de le souligner ici
dans les départements de la région PACA
Sud Marine Le Pen arrive en tête bien
souvent et dans de très nombreuses
communes à l'exception des plus grandes
villes Marseille par exemple ami
Emmanuel Macron en tête Aix-en-Provence
également Avignon dans le Vaucluse ami
Emmanuel Macron en tête c'est le cas
également de Manosque et de
Digne-les-Bains dans les
Alpes-de-Haute-Provence mais à part ces
grandes villes là il faut bien le
reconnaître que la plupart des communes
ont propulsé la candidate du
rassemblement national devant et parfois
très loin devant à l'image de la commune
de Fos-sur-Mer ou de Port-Saint-Louis
pourtant d'anciens bastions ouvriers
communistes ou là Marine Le Pen tangente
les 70% de voix c'est également le cas à
Marignane ou la candidate du
rassemblement national enregistre plus
de 55% des suffrages on a signalé aussi
Alex vous ne l'avez très bien dit le
vote dans les outre-mer ou là Marine Le
Pen est arrivée
largement en tête et quelles conséquence
maintenant pour Emmanuel Macron face à
cette France fracturée est-ce qu'on peut
s'attendre à un climat social tendu
Nathalie voire un retour des gilets
jaunes ou pire une plus grande colère
encore dans la rue moi je n'irai pas sur
ce terrain là
la France est fracturée certes est-ce
qu'il faut en conclure tout de suite que
les gens vont descendre dans la rue
non je crois pas je peut-être que ça
arrivera mais je pense pas que c'est
c'est le cas aujourd'hui aujourd'hui un
président qui est élu il y a une
recomposition politique en cours il y a
des élections législatives le 18 et le
19 faut pas non plus effectivement il y
a une partie de la France qui sans doute
en colère et il faut quand même garder
en tête que parmi les électeurs de
d'Emmanuel Macron seul 53% ont voté pour
lui le reste c'est à dire 47% ont voté
pour faire front
au rassemblement national mais en même
temps est-ce que les gens ont envie tout
de suite de de se battre dans la rue je
suis pas sûr moi je sens quand j'écoute
les lecteurs que j'ai pu rencontrer
durant cette campagne électorale il y a
aussi une volonté de sortir un peu de de
des années de crise qui est aussi assez
importante donc ce qui se passera à
l'automne c'est pas forcément ce qui va
se passer tout de suite donc pour
l'instant il faut que Emmanuel Macron
donne des signes importants il l'a dit
hier alors de façon effectivement un peu
classique en cochant des cases de ce
qu'il fallait dire et de ne pas dire
mais il doit donner des signes
importants y compris dans la composition
de son gouvernement y compris voilà
c'est c'est dans cette séquence là qu'on
entre plus que dans en descend dans la
rue pour pour se battre c'est pour qu'il
y ait un combat social des tensions dans
la rue il faut qu'il y ait et bien un
point de cristallisation on imagine que
ce point de cristallisation ça peut être
par exemple la réforme des retraites à
65 ans d'Emmanuel Macron donc tout
l'enjeu de sa stratégie ça va être de
voir comment il va décliner cette
réforme est-ce qu'il par exemple il va
commencer par et bien réaliser les
parties sociales de cette réforme en
augmentant par exemple la retraite
minimale à 1100 euros et ce qui va déjà
donner des gages sociaux pour après
arriver sur la partie financière du
système des retraites c'est ce qu'on va
voir comment Emmanuel la combe elle va
éviter
à la colère de cette France là qui n'a
pas voté pour lui par adhésion mais pour
faire barrage à Marine Le Pen et en même
temps satisfaire son électorat qui a
voté par adhésion et qui lui attend ses
réformes alors écoutez la question de
savoir si ce que les choses vont mal se
passer ou pas je pense que tout dépendra
de l'attitude que doctorat Emmanuel
Macron dans les jours les semaines qui
viennent
on a beaucoup glosé sur le discours
d'hier soir j'aime bien le le
l'expression de l'évier Biscay qui dit
ce sera un petit président s'il va pas
au-delà des mots et c'est exactement ça
parce que ce qui nous a promis hier soir
le discours hier soir c'est le même que
celui de 2017 le même en disant il
s'adressait à l'époque aux électeurs en
fait puisque exactement il a même pas
faire référence au recul de l'époque il
s'adressait je vous rappelle qu'à
l'époque c'était adressé aux électeurs
de Marine Le Pen au second tour en
disant je ferai tout pour que ces
électeurs-là n'aient plus aucune raison
de voter pour les extrêmes dans 5 ans
bah excusez-moi mais le vote extrême
entre le vote la France insoumise et le
vote rassemblement national en 2022 là
je peux dire on peut dire que c'est un
échec manifeste donc au cours de son
quinquennat il a promis plusieurs fois
de changer de méthode de changer
d'attitude de de de de
se transformer etc d'être plus à
l'écoute et à chaque fois il a eu des
changements de pieds qui font qu'en fait
on peut douter de ce qui va faire c'est
pas parce qu'il a tenu un beau discours
hier qui va faire effectivement ce qu'il
a promis donc il faut maintenant qu'il
dépasse le stade des mots et que très
vite il traduisent en acte un certain
nombre de choses sinon effectivement le
risque c'est que la marmite elle
continue à bouillonner et là où je
rejoins complètement Nathalie c'est que
à mon avis le premier signe qui doit
envoyer il sera autour du choix du
Premier ministre ou de la première
ministre et de la composition de son
gouvernement et ça c'est quelque chose
qui qui va débouler dans les dans les
dans les jours qui viennent et ensuite
il y aura un certain nombre de dossiers
ou de mesures fortes pour lesquelles il
faut qu'ils prennent des décisions
symboliques et qui montre bien qu'il est
en train d'impulser autre chose parce
que si on reste dans la dialectique ou
ça y est j'ai gagné j'ai les mains
libres j'ai 5 ans pour tout changer je
vais faire ce que les choses comme j'ai
envie et au rythme que je souhaite là ça
risque de mal se passer oui je rejoins
Stéphane il faut toujours rejoindre
Stéphane d'ailleurs mais
il y a des chiffres qui moi m'ont marqué
il y a Ipsos qui montrait hier que il y
avait quand on parlait de l'élection de
la réélection d'Emmanuel Macron aux gens
les Français répondaient 46%
des mots négatifs et 34% seulement des
mots positifs parmi ces mots positifs
10% qui parlaient d'espoir c'est dire si
l'élection de d'Emmanuel Macron
c'est colère voilà donc autant vous dire
que cette réélection elle s'inscrit dans
un dans un climat qui est très
particulier et il est réélu parce que
c'est une valeur quasi refuge dans une
période anxiogène qui est quand même
dominé aussi par l'actualité guerrière
aux frontières de l'Europe et finalement
peu de gens se disent que les choses
vont s'améliorer à la à l'heure actuelle
grâce à lui ça veut dire que dans les
signes qui doit qui doit engager il y a
clairement cette notion de d'espoir à
reconstruire parce que s'il n'arrive pas
à reconstruire cet espoir très
sincèrement les gens continueront soit
de ne pas aller voter puisque l'autre
élément on a finalement on peut parler
mais il y a quand même une abstention
qui est inédite depuis 19
et donc si s'il y a bien un élément qui
est là c'est cette défection vis-à-vis
de la démocratie donc il faut
reconstruire les sports auprès de ces
gens-là reconstruire les sports auprès
de des gens qui sont partis aller à
l'extrême droite et ça ça passe
évidemment par des signaux très clairs
le Premier ministre mais aussi la
méthode normalement il doit lancer des
le chantier de quelques réformes les
retraites la santé l'éducation via une
je le cite une méthode refondée
collective une réinvention qu'on nous a
déjà servi et c'est bien ça le problème
et donc là aussi il faudra des signaux
très concrets et très rapides pour
montrer cet engagement
et un dernier mot juste à Olivier qu'on
libère après je vous donne la parole
Nathalie Olivier la priorité pour
Emmanuel Macron c'est d'envoyer des
signaux pour recoudre cette transfacturé
une rupture et je n'ai pas entendu votre
question je vous en prie je vous la
repose Olivier la priorité pour Emmanuel
Macron c'est d'envoyer des signaux pour
recoudre cette France fracturé qu'on
décrit depuis tout à l'heure
oui c'est envoyé des signaux on le dit
de depuis tout à l'heure je crois en
effet que le gouvernement sera ainsi
mais plus globalement je pense que
évidemment Emmanuel Macron a un rôle a
joué dans cette histoire je pense que la
les formations politiques ont tout aussi
des ambitions à avoir sur sur le sujet
regardez ce qui se passe depuis ce matin
enfin j'ai l'impression qu'il ne s'est
rien passé hier soir finalement elle est
elle est fille le Parti socialiste était
sous votre plateau sur votre plateau
tout à l'heure j'ai eu l'impression
qu'on était en 2017 en 2019 on était le
23 avril
2022 comme si hier soir il n'y avait pas
eu de message envoyé par les français
bien sûr qu'il y a eu un message envoyé
à Emmanuel Macron on le sait bien c'est
le président sortant mais tous les
autres alors que font-ils il y a tout de
même des bulletins de blanc dans les
urnes il y a tout de même des gens qui
se sont abstenus et pas simplement parce
qu'ils étaient contre Emmanuel Macron
mais aussi contre probablement et on l'a
vu sur le terrain on l'a entendu
Nathalie le disait avec les lecteurs
c'est pareil ici chez nous des gens nous
allons assez du système qui est là
aujourd'hui et quel que soit je dirais
ce qui est en train de se passer je
crois qu'il y a aussi un peu une
cohésion à retrouver alors c'est
évidemment des grands mots et je suis
pas du tout un chevalier blanc je suis
un journaliste mais un peu de cohésion à
retrouver au plan au plan local au plan
des politiques aussi de se dire mais
qu'est-ce qu'on a raté ces dernières
années et qu'est-ce qu'on peut arranger
Macron à sacrée responsabilité totale
parce qu'il est présent de la République
mais tous les autres ont aussi à
regarder un petit peu leur boutique pour
que retisser le lien dans le chacune des
territoires surtout quand on regarde les
résultats ville par ville département
par département certains présidents de
conseil départementaux certains maires
n'ont pas à faire la gloriole ce matin
parce que c'est assez catastrophique et
merci beaucoup Olivier au revoir à la du
Midi Libre entendez et agissez c'est la
une ce matin de votre journal merci
Olivier Biscay d'avoir été avec nous ce
matin Nathalie je vous redonne la parole
oui juste pour appuyer ce que disait
Olivier si on ajoute les gens qui se
sont abstenus le nombre de gens qui se
sont absolus les bulletins blancs et les
bulletins nuls on arrive à un score
super supérieur à celui d'Emmanuel
Macron au premier tour
donc ça pose une voilà Emmanuel Macron
il a fait 9 millions de voix au premier
tour et au deuxième tour et ben ça fait
plus j'ai plus le chiffre en tête mais
s'il doit faire à peu près 13 millions
de gens qui se sont abstenus qui ont
voté blanc ou qui ont voté nul on voit
bien que ça ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui
son assise à lectorat électorale est
faible et on va parler des législatives
maintenant présenter comme le troisième
tour un dès les premières minutes
après l'annonce du résultat l'opposition
est tout de suite monté au front Alex le
troisième tour est lancé avec d'abord
cette question qui se pose Emmanuel
Macron va-t-il réussir à avoir une
majorité à l'Assemblée nationale pour
pouvoir gouverner sereinement en tout
cas le président du groupe en marche à
l'Assemblée Christophe Castaner lui n'en
doute pas ce matin et il a même répondu
à la question d'une éventuelle alliance
avec les républicains pour rater encore
plus l'âge encore plus large dans ces
élections on l'écoute tous les
républicains qui veulent travailler aux
côtés d'Emmanuel Macron pour un projet
pour notre pays sont les bienvenus pour
s'engager avec nous mais pas à leurs
conditions et donc évidemment sur la
base du projet politique qui a été
validé par les Français hier dans
l'élection
et face à cette appel d'air des Verts
Emmanuel Macron et bien le patron des LR
Christian Jacob lui répond en tout cas
hier soir il disait que son parti de
vérité indépendant et mener cette
campagne des législatives seules on va
l'écouter nous sommes ni fongibles dans
le pénis ni dans le macroniste il y a
une force indépendante de droite et de
centre droit qui doit exister à
l'Assemblée nationale et nous avons les
candidats pour cela voilà c'est le
leitmotiv qui est répété c'est dernier
jour par Christian Jacob du côté du
Rassemblement National Marine Le Pen
elle a déjà appelé à hier soir au
rassemblement encore plus large que son
mouvement pour faire un bon score dans
Célé législatives
vocation à élargir ce pôle populaire qui
a été constitué lors de la
présidentielle pour bâtir une majorité
alternative à l'Assemblée nationale et
donc gouverner ce pays dans quelques
semaines ces élections législatives vont
fonctionner comme un troisième tour de
l'élection présidentielle
vous l'avez compris ce n'était pas
Marine Le Pen c'est-à-dire maintenant le
coordinateur de la France insoumise qui
évoquait cette union du bloc de gauche
en vue des législatives on va donc voir
si on peut écouter Marine Le Pen sur
cette union cette fois-ci à l'extrême
droite en vue de ces élections
tremblement national œuvrera à unir tout
ce dont ils viennent qui veulent se
rassembler et rassembler leur force
contre la politique d'Emmanuel Macron le
score historique de ce soir place notre
camp dans d'excellentes dispositions
pour obtenir un grand nombre de députés
en juin prochain et il y en a un qui
veut bien saluer avec Marine Le Pen en
vue de ses élections mais les
discussions risquent d'être un petit peu
tendus c'est Éric Zemmour désormais
patron de son parti reconquête lui il
rêve de former un bloc à des droites qui
pourraient l'emporter en juin prochain
pâtisson au plus vite la première
coalition des droites et des patriotes
pour que les élus de reconquête du
rassemblement national de Debout la
France et ceux des républicains qui ne
veulent pas se rallier à Emmanuel Macron
est une chance de peser voir de dominer
dans la prochaine assemblée on finit par
la gauche on a entendu tout à l'heure
Adrien catenin sur et bien ce bloc
populaire autour de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
mais il faudra peut-être aussi compter
avec les socialistes qui ont quand même
une trentaine de députés actuellement
une trentaine de circonscriptions ils
sont toujours implantés dans les
territoires elles ne sont pas
complètement fini et en tout cas Olivier
fort lui il croit à cette union de la
gauche en vue des législatives il faut
que la gauche se réunissent sans
exclusive qu'elle fasse la démonstration
qu'elle peut porter un projet commun et
qu'elle aille devant les électeurs en
ayant cette capacité à convaincre et
peut-être même à gagner c'est ce que je
souhaite et voilà Olivier fort qui croit
toujours
et on voit aussi bien du côté DLR que du
PS qui ont fait des scores
historiquement faibles et bien il compte
sur les législatives pour se relancer
Stéphane oui c'est beau tout le monde y
croire donc voilà c'est très difficile
bon écoutez moi ce que ce que je trouve
intéressant dans cette histoire c'est
que
Emmanuel Macron est le premier président
de la 5e République à l'issue d'un
quinquennat qui réussit à être élu pour
un deuxième donc c'est historique il
pourrait aussi tout à fait être le
premier président de la Cinquième
République élu qui se voit imposer une
cohabitation d'emblée au législatif qui
suit sauf que c'est pas sûr du tout tout
est possible en réalité ce qui sera
intéressant regardez dans ces
législatives ça va être passionnant à
suivre quand on est journaliste
politique pour le grand public je suis
pas sûr que ce soit tout aussi
passionnant on verra bien à l'arrivée je
vais rebondir sur ce que disait Olivier
Biscaye aussi tout à l'heure qui disait
très justement qu'en fait la montée de
du vote des votes extrêmes c'est pas le
seul fait de l'attitude d'Emmanuel
Macron de ses échecs ou de son
comportement non c'est aussi la
traduction du fait que pour un très
grand nombre de Françaises et de
français aujourd'hui les politiques de
notre scène nationale sont tous nuls
n'en veulent plus ça marche plus ça les
intéresse plus et le premier le premier
aspect qui sera intéressant à analyser
dans ces futurs législatives ce sera le
taux de participation parce que si on se
retrouve avec un taux de participation
très faible comme c'est très souvent le
cas des législatives après une
présidentielle jusqu'à maintenant ce
sera bien la marque que les Françaises
et les Françaises se désintéressent
totalement de leur scène politique
nationale et ça c'est avec la pour le
coup des problématiques conséquences
puisque le mode de vie
12,5% des inscrits alors pour être
second tour ça je pense que ça fait
partie aussi des très grands chantiers
enfin des chantiers d'importance que le
Président de la République sur lequel le
président de la République va devoir
envoyer des signes très fort et très
vite toutes les histoires de réforme des
institutions et gouvernance me passionne
peut-être pas a priori des gens mais je
pense que c'est fondamental à partir du
moment où vous vous avez quand même
beaucoup de citoyens et de citoyens si
ce n'est la majorité qui disent qu'ils
ne se sentent plus représenter par les
gens qui se présentent en leur nom quand
même quand vous avez 12 candidats sur
une présidentielle tout le spectre
politique qui représenté et les gens
vous disent mais moi aucun de ceux-là ne
magrait je ne me sens pas représenté en
n'écoute pas en me comprend pas il y a
un souci et donc je pense qu'il faudra
très vite trouver des solutions
introduire de la proportionnelle prendre
en compte le bulletin de le bulletin
blanc que sais-je mais en tout cas il va
falloir inventer des nouvelles choses et
le faire assez vite pour renouer le fil
parce que parce que sinon le système il
excusez-moi mais il est en train de
mourir de sa belle-mère et le à ce titre
là législatives vont être très
intéressantes et regardez avant de vous
de laisser la conclusion Julien Nathalie
puisque Stéphane parlait pour l'instant
de cette France qui se sent pas
représentée dans cette France il y a
notamment les quartiers populaires et
vous en parlez ce matin vous Guilhem
dans La Provence
oui effectivement on est allé en
reportage hier dans les cités dans les
quartiers populaires de Marseille ou
c'est un petit peu paradoxal d'ailleurs
Oriane puisqu'à la fois il y a une très
forte mobilisation il y avait une très
forte mobilisation contre les idées de
l'extrême droite beaucoup de personnes
rencontrées par notre reporter nous
l'ont dit il fallait faire barrage
massivement à Marine Le Pen et
d'ailleurs au premier tour c'est
Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui était très
largement arrivé en tête dans dans
certaines ces quartiers et le paradoxe
c'est que dans ces mêmes quartiers et
bien des habitants expliqués que Marine
Le Pen était peut-être aussi la seule
capable de redresser la France et donc
pour ses habitants parfois issus de
l'immigration et bien hier il y avait
aussi l'évidence que le vote du
rassemblement national était peut-être
l'une des solutions aux mots que
connaissent par ces particulièrement ces
quartiers vous le voyez deux visages
différents dans des mêmes quartiers et
deux approches très différentes de ce
que doit être la société il va falloir
parler à cette France avant et légis
Julien est juste un chiffre puisqu'on en
a pas parlé dans notre sondage ipso
sopra terrestre 56% des Français veulent
qu'Emmanuel Macron perd ses législatives
de cohabitation ce qui est assez assez
incroyable quand on
les circonstances actuelles mais qui
traduisent une réalité c'est à dire
qu'encore une fois Emmanuel Emmanuel
Macron a vu comme une valeur refuge mais
qu'on veut une sorte de contre-pouvoir
parce qu'on estime que son pouvoir a été
trop jupiterien trop vertical et donc et
ça on n'en veut pas mais ça montre aussi
que les réformes institutionnelles sont
vraiment l'une des l'un des signaux
encore rapides qu'il faut engager ça
rend d'autant plus dommageable le fait
que ça n'a pas été le cas durant le
quinquennat précédent parce que je
reprends l'expression de du
constitutionnaliste de microso la France
a besoin de démocratie continue et ça ça
passe à la fois par la proportionnelle
mais aussi par les référendum il y a
quelque chose à réinventer et la
conclusion ce dont on a peut-être peu ce
matin on a dit qu'effectivement Emmanuel
Macron était réélu de façon tout à fait
claire que on a parlé de la poussée du
Front national on a peut-être pas trop
insisté finalement sur l'effondrement
des deux parties traditionnels donc la
gauche et la droite le Parti socialiste
et républicains ça indique quoi ça
indique que
la gauche et la droite ça veut plus rien
dire et qu'on est finalement sur un
autre clivage politique
quelle forme prendra cet autre clivage
politique dans cette semaine lors des
législatifs c'est ça qui est important
finalement est-ce que on va arriver sur
un bipartisme c'est à dire sur une un
bloc élitaire un bloc populiste est-ce
que contraire on va sur un voilà ça
c'est la recomposition qui en marche et
c'est à mon avis une leçon importante de
cette présidente
au quotidien régionaux avec Alex
et Alex évidemment tous les titres ont
moi cette élection présidentielle à la
une de la presse régionale intégralement
sur ce second tour de la présidentielle
mais toutes les unes ne se ressemblent
pas il y a d'abord et bien les une très
factuelle comme et bien celle de
l'Alsace repartit pour 5 ans réélu pour
le Dauphiné Macron élu avec son score de
58,5% des voix c'est elle a une de la
dépêche ou encore et bien Var-Matin à 50
plus c'est le début de l'acte 2 titre
sud-ouest aujourd'hui et c'est la même
idée à la une du Courrier Picard Macron
de c'est d'ailleurs le premier président
de la République à être réélu sans
s'appuyer sur une période de
cohabitation Macron aurait élu oui mais
et c'est une idée qui est bien résumé
par la Une du journal La Provence
puisque et bien ce président a été élu
avec un score plus faible qu'il y a 5
ans une extrême droite à plus de 40%,
une abstention
très forte cela propose donc et bien des
questions et maintenant se demandent
Corse-Matin tout reste à faire estime le
Berry Républicain Emmanuel Macron en est
conscient il l'a dit ce vote m'oblige
c'est à la Une des Dernières Nouvelles
d'Alsace car beaucoup de ces électeurs
au second tour voulait uniquement faire
barrage à Marine Le Pen et n’approuve
pas la politique des manuels Macron
c'est donc dans un pays divisé
qu'Emmanuel Macron va commencer son
deuxième quinquennat une France à
rassembler titre Le Courrier de l'Ouest
réconcilier très vite c'est l'impératif
que pose la Nouvelle République une
France a apaisé estime et bien là
Charente Libre et on finit très
rapidement rien par le journal de
saône-et-loir qui lui est bien estime
que le troisième tour est lancé
effectivement et législative tout comme
la Marseillaise et on regarde vaut une
la une du progrès Nathalie Macron obligé
de changer la Une de Ouest-France
Emmanuel Macron réélu c'est simple
efficace la Une de La non c'est votre
m'oblige et la Une de La Provence oui
mais merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous
[Musique]